[MUSIC PLAYING]
[INAUDIBLE]
RETO MEIER: Or you can post your
thoughts in the G+ event
or the YouTube comments.
And producer Dan is going to
read those out for you, if you
are too shy to join us live
on the telly box.
While we give folks a chance to
get their thoughts together
and join us on the Hangouts,
I'm going to cover a few
points that have already been
raised by some of the
developer audience on
the Google+ page.
Those of you who have joined us
on the Hangout, thank you
for joining us.
We'll get Daniel in touch with
you via text on that, so that
we can queue you up
and get you ready
to share your thoughts.
So
DAN: Sorry about that.
I cut out the first 10 seconds
of your intro, the welcome,
and if you're watching
[INAUDIBLE]
and all that stuff.
Sorry about that.
RETO MEIER: That's all right.
Not a problem.
Just so everyone knows, this is
After the Table Flip, talk
radio style, chance for everyone
to tell me how right
I was, or how wrong I was.
I somehow suspect we'll
get more of the
latter than the former.
Just because, if you agree then
there's not a lot to say.
So we're going to get some
folks on Hangout as well.
I'm going to start off by
answering some of the
questions from people on
the G+ event and the
YouTube live streams.
So if you do have questions and
you prefer not to be on
video, do throw them in there.
And producer Dan will respond
on your behalf.
So on G+, developer Jacob
[? Nordfolk ?]
represented probably the most
common argument against what I
was presenting in today's
table flip.
And that is, that there's a
lot of user pressure or
dissatisfaction.
Because users, quote, "don't
know how to quit the program."
And I think I covered
the argument
against that pretty well.
But let's be a little bit more
specific in two examples.
So in Jacob's case, he's talking
about two internet
radio apps that he has built.
And in his experience, users
have failed to find the Stop
button to stop the music.
Now he's pointed out that in his
particular use case, he's
not allowed to make the Stop
button more prominent.
And so this is a genuine
problem.
So what I would say is, have a
look at the way that Google
music actually solves this.
And so really it's about
making sure that Stop--
stopping the music, stopping
the resource consumption--
is really, really
easy to find.
So Google music does this by
having the Stop controls along
the bottom of every activity,
whenever the app is running.
Or if the app isn't running but
the music is playing, then
there's an ongoing notification,
which has rich
notifications.
Which again allows you
to stop the music.
And in addition to that, there's
also the lock screen,
which you can then configure--
and which Google music does--
to allow you to stop
playback as well.
And so the solution here,
particularly for music playing
apps, is that all of those
things I've just described are
totally available to any
third-party app.
And so by doing things like
this, it makes it really,
really easy.
Even if the Stop button doesn't
have to be half the
screen, it's just everywhere
they look there's a really
obvious place to find it.
And that's going to be much more
reliable than having an
Exit button, which a
lot of users aren't
going to find anyway.
User demands for an Exit button
almost always correlate
to an app that has confusing
navigation, or hard to find
controls, or is a
resource hog.
So adding an Exit button is
going to stop users from
asking you to add
an Exit button.
But it's kind of like giving
an aspirin to a patient
complaining of chronic
abdominal pains.
They will stop asking
for the painkillers.
But that doesn't actually get
rid of their problem.
So you're better off trying to
treat the underlying cause
rather than the symptom.
And similarly, Daniel [? Drew ?]
asks, how would you
implement the browser featured
of ditching all cookies on
exit, if you don't have
an Exit button?
And that's actually a really
good question.
In practice I think there's an
assumption that mobile devices
are inherently more personal
than computers.
So privacy features like
the removal of
cookies when you exit--
which were really designed
around ensuring the
credentials used by different
users on the same computer--
don't leak, when your wife,
girlfriend, husband, whoever,
uses your computer.
So those sorts of features
aren't quite as important for
a phone, with the implicit
assumption is that there's
only going to be one
person using it.
And in fact, it even almost goes
the other way, where the
pain associated with having to
put in your credentials or
into the same information
multiple times, is actually
significantly more annoying
on a phone
than it is on a computer.
So there's even more reason to
hang on to some of this stuff.
So that said, if you did want to
do something like that, the
suggestion I would have is
probably to have a menu
option, probably a settings
option to clear all cookies.
Or better still, maybe a menu
item, which says something
like "close all windows and
clear all cookies." Or it just
says "close all windows and
clear all cookies" is one of
the option that you have.
So that's answer to two
of those questions.
What should we go
to next, Dan?
Have we got folks on the Hangout
which would like to
vent their spleen?
DAN: We don't have
anyone explicitly
asking for time on camera.
But if any of you guys in the
Hangout right now want to
comment, we can definitely
put you air.
So just let us now.
RETO MEIER: I think we should
put people on the spot.
If they're joining the Hangout,
we're going to assume
that they've got something
to say.
So pick someone who looks like
they're enjoying themselves.
The guy in the red shirt.
Let's pop him online and
see what he's got to
share with us all.
DAN: All right.
The guy in the red shirt would
be Jay [? McGill. ?]
I'm not going to say
his whole name.
RETO MEIER: He can introduce
himself.
You want to pop him
up on the screen.
And let him know.
And unmute him.
Because I suspect he's muted.
DAN: All right.
RETO MEIER: I think
he's still muted.
DAN: Hey, how are you doing?
Can you hear us?
RETO MEIER: We can't hear him.
Have you got
DAN: Here we go.
RETO MEIER: Now we
can hear you.
So what do you think?
Am I full of it?
Or am onto something?
AUDIENCE: You're absolutely
right.
And I was curious if there
are any other options?
I mean, are there people that
think that the Exit button
makes any sense?
RETO MEIER: There are.
There are a surprisingly large
number people which disagree
with the basic premise.
I think it's usually
around users.
That seems to be the feedback I
get from most developers, is
that they're like, yeah,
we don't want to do it.
But our users keep
asking for them.
And so I think a big part of
it is trying to explain.
And a lot of the time
what they're saying
is, well that's fine.
But you need to explain to users
why they don't need an
Exit button.
But what I've actually found is
that it's easier to explain
to developers how to build apps
that people aren't asking
for those Exit buttons.
That kind of tends to be
the most common thing.
They're like, I didn't
want to do it.
But people kept asking for it,
so I had to build it in.
So it's really about trying to
explain to devs how you can
build apps which don't have
people asking those questions.
AUDIENCE: In the end, if the
client does ask for it--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: They're
paying for it.
They get it.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
Of course, I guess that's the
other case which I haven't
really talked much about is,
what happens when you're
building an app for someone.
And they say, we want
an Exit button.
Well, you have to do what
the client says.
But really it's about trying to
create an atmosphere where
people feel comfortable at least
telling their clients
that, this is an anti-pattern.
This is not what Android users
are going to expect.
And being able to say that
with some authority.
And that's a big part of what
the design guidelines on
developeratandroid.com/design
are really about, is helping
to create sort of an expectation
of, this is what
Android apps are.
So if you're asking for
something different, then it's
counter to what people
are expecting.
I think there's a lot of
background which we have to
get past, of people being used
to old feature phone J2ME
apps, which have
an Exit button.
Because they were sort
of single tasking.
Or even iPhone, which uses a
slightly different model for
the way that they do things.
And so a lot of it is education,
both the developers
and users, and clients,
which seem to
somehow fit in between.
DAN: Anyone else
on the Hangout?
I'm going to put you guys on
the spot and just select
someone at random if
no one volunteers.
AUDIENCE: I just want to jump
in real quick before I
have to head out.
RETO MEIER: Hi Ryan.
AUDIENCE How're you doing?
RETO MEIER: Good mate.
DAN: All right, Ryan.
Go ahead.
You're live.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
So I just want to agree with
Reto with the whole activity
life cycle thing.
A lot of people say that you
need that Exit button to exit
that app and get it
out of their mind.
I guess a lot of people probably
just don't fully
understand that life cycle,
where it goes in the
background, stays in the
background for a little bit.
You have to adjust for that
whole life cycle pattern of
going through on Pause, and then
on Stop, and making sure
you clear up the things that
you're appropriately doing
with your app in those
life cycles.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, I think
the life cycle stuff--
it's kind of the most
fundamental thing about Android.
Which makes it really different
to anything I've
ever done before.
I was a Windows programmer
before Android.
You're not really thinking in
those sorts of terms, of the
OS telling you what's happening
to your app.
You capture some of those
things, like on-form leave,
and on-control focus
and stuff.
But it's never to control
your resource usage.
It's just to decide
whether your app
should be doing something.
And I always think that's kind
of the big challenge.
Once you really get the life
cycle stuff in your head,
everything else just
kind of makes
sense and kind of follows.
Is that similar to
your experience?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I definitely agree
in that aspect.
A lot of people probably
just don't see that.
Us being developers, you
know that life cycle.
You know it's happening in
the background, what
is supposed to happen.
Maybe the users just don't
see that, right?
In the foreground of, oh there's
a life cycle going on
and this is what needs
to happen.
And so maybe they're
feeling like there
should be an Exit button.
When in reality, you really
don't need one.
So you're definitely
not crazy.
I see where you're
coming from.
So I just wanted to
let you know that.
RETO MEIER: Cool, thanks Ryan.
I appreciate that.
All right.
Cool.
Do we have any other questions
on either the Livestream or on
G+ or YouTube?
Oh someone's got his
hand up in the--
DAN: All right, yeah.
Let's put him on.
This is Dave.
RETO MEIER: Hey Dave.
DAN: Go ahead, Dave.
You're live.
AUDIENCE: Yeah I just want a
quick comment about what the
previous speaker said.
I think it's going to take a
little while for people to get
used to that.
I think we're so--
even a few years ago, or a
couple years ago maybe with
Vista or something like that--
we're so used to closing down
stuff and making sure RAM is
available and all that stuff.
That we need to really get used
to knowing that if an app
is done properly, sitting in the
background, not consuming
resources, not pinging the
server and so on and so forth.
I think that's really going to
take a couple of years before
people understand and are
aware of that, and are
comfortable just leaving apps
open just by hitting the Back
button and back to
the home screen.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
I think there's a big challenge
there for us as
developers as well.
It's making sure that
users feel really
comfortable doing that.
And this is the thing, if you
have a whole bunch of apps,
and then you go back to the home
screen and your device
starts running real slow, that's
a terrible experience.
It's no wonder users are going
to be like, I just want to
know how to exit all
of these apps.
And so I think the framework
team here at Google have done
a lot of work in that direction,
to try and make the
blame more visible.
So things like battery drain
and those sorts of things--
you can see which apps
are doing it.
And so the blame goes to them,
rather than to the system.
And if you're doing these
things right-- if you're
suspending all of your
listeners, turning off your
updates, not doing background
refreshes
or any of that stuff--
then your app will never get
blamed for anything.
And no one's ever going to call
into question as to, how
can I get rid of this.
Because it's just there.
And it just works.
But yeah.
I think that's the challenge.
You've got reach that critical
mass where most apps are doing
the right thing.
And then users are going to be
like, why would I exit it?
That's just going to
slow stuff down.
AUDIENCE: Mm hmm.
DAN: Cool.
So Ali, hey, I notice that you
have a question in the chat?
Do you want to ask Reto live?
You're on air.
AUDIENCE: I just asked
what I could do--
I'm actually just starting to
start to develop and whatnot.
So I want to know, are there
any resources that you can
actually provide, or that
Google provides, about
learning more about
the life cycle?
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
So I posted a link.
So links to all of the stuff
that I showed in the intro
video there, on the YouTube
site, I'll post it into G+
event as well.
But to answer your question more
specifically, if you go
to
developer.android.com/training,
we have a bunch of intro level
classes to help explain the
basic building blocks
of Android.
And I think the life cycle
stuff is Lesson One.
It's kind of that fundamental.
So if you want to get a better
understanding of what it
means, how does it work,
what's the right way of
dealing with it, then definitely
check that out.
And that should help
you get started.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RETO MEIER: No worries.
And good luck with everything.
It should be a lot of fun.
We look forward to seeing
what you come up with.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
DAN: All right guys.
Who's up next?
Just go ahead, raise your hand,
and I'm on the Hangout,
and I'll put you guys live.
Anyone?
All right.
Here we go.
Sorry, I'm not quite sure how
to pronounce your name.
Why don't you go ahead and
introduce yourself.
RETO MEIER: Oh Yossi.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
from Google+.
Nicely done, man.
How you doing?
I think you muted yourself.
DAN: Yeah.
Still nothing.
Why don't you go ahead
and check your mic.
Still nothing.
RETO MEIER: We're not hearing
you unfortunately, Yossi.
AUDIENCE: Can you hear me now?
RETO MEIER: We can
hear you now.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Sorry.
A couple of mics over
here, so I needed to
choose the correct one.
First of all, hi Reto.
I don't know if you remember
me from the Google I/O?
RETO MEIER: Vaguely.
I meet a lot of people at I/O.
AUDIENCE: I know.
Basically what I wanted to refer
to was the Exit button.
In our app, we use video-social
communication,
Chat and IM messaging
and so on.
And basically we have users
wanting to exit the
application in fully, not just
doing a signout and leaving
the service running or
something like that.
Basically they want to exit
the application, so our
service will die at the
same point they want.
So I'm referring to it
as a bad pattern.
Because that's more like a
single task device and not the
Android system.
But basically, if we need to
implement such behavior, then
the Exit button should be a part
of the Android pattern.
Although the Android system is
killing tasks by itself.
RETO MEIER: I think the
challenge in a situation like
that is similar to what you're
going to see things like
GoogleTalk or any ongoing
messaging thing where--
the user wants the ability to
basically say, disconnect from
your server.
And stop consuming everything.
So in that case, the culmination
of hitting logout
or signout from the service,
and then listening for
on-pause should be enough.
So that once they say
disconnect, that should be the
equivalent of hitting
Exit, basically.
AUDIENCE: That's what
we implemented.
We have both features.
We have the feature
of signout.
So we'll show the user the
home screen to log in via
Facebook or his username
and password.
And we also have the Exit button
that keeps the user
logged into the system, but
basically exits all the
applications and kills the
service and everything.
And then all messaging or
notifications comes via GCM or
T2DM to all the devices.
RETO MEIER: So that's
interesting.
That brings up a really
good point.
Kind of what I was alluding to
earlier-- like, if you hadn't
told me that, if I just opened
your app and saw Logout and
Exit as two separate options, I
would have no idea what the
Exit button would do.
I certainly wouldn't expect that
if I hit Exit, that I'd
still get messages from GCM.
I would expect that if you hit
Exit, everything turns off.
So I log out, and I stop
getting messages.
I think that's the challenge.
If you introduce something like
Exit, which doesn't have
a clear semantic meaning, then
different users are going to
interpret it in different
ways.
And so, logout totally
makes sense.
Disconnect me from
your services.
I don't want to get
any more messages.
100% makes sense.
Exit--
it doesn't.
Basically what you're describing
what the Exit
button does, it sounds to me
like what should happen when I
hit Back or Home from
within your app
AUDIENCE: That's what
I'm saying.
But because we're doing cross
platform, so we want our users
to know that the device or
application handles the same
situations all over
the platforms.
So basically if you have an Exit
button on iPhone, or you
have an Exit button on Windows,
or on Windows phone
tablets and so on, or even on
Mac-- you press command Q, you
exit the app.
And on Android, the ecosystem is
just, hit the Home button,
and let Android deal with all
the memory and all the tasks
ongoing, and so on.
So what is the best option to
handle the situation for us
and also give the user the same
atmosphere, or the same
experience, when moving
from device to device?
Because basically the user
connects from an iPod, an
iPhone, an iPad, a Nexus 7,
Nexus 10, Google TV--
you name the device,
we have it.
So basically we want the users
to know that [? UVU ?]
connects people all
over the world.
No matter what, the same
experience, the same features
are available on all devices.
So that's the main issue here.
RETO MEIER: OK.
That's a good question.
And it's actually an
interesting one.
Because I hear this a lot from
developers who are building
these cross platform solutions,
where they want to
have something really consistent
across all the
different devices.
Now the thing is, there's sort
of two different ways that I
would approach this.
And the first is that it's
actually fairly unlikely that
you're going to have a
significant number of users
which have multiple different
devices from different
manufacturers.
So you're not going to have a
lot of people which have an
IPhone and an Android phone.
There will be some--
and this leads me to my second
point, which is that people
expect their devices to
behave consistently.
They don't necessarily expect
apps to work exactly the same
across different devices.
So if I've got an iPad, then I
expect all of the apps to work
in a way that's consistent with
the way all of the other
iPad apps work.
And if I have Android,
then I expect them to
all work with Android.
So what you don't have is an
iPhone user expecting their
Android phone to work in the
same way as their iPhone.
Because it's a different
device, right?
They don't have the
same expectations.
If they did, they get really
confused when they started
using things like Mail and Maps
and Music and Twitter and
everything else.
Because they just inherently
behave differently.
And it's the same
with computers.
You expect your computer to
work in a certain way.
Expect to have that command Q
to get out of an app in Mac.
If you've got Windows,
you expect to
be able to hit Alt-F4.
But what you're not
expecting is--
a good example is, if you're
building an app for both
Windows and Mac, you're not
going to build the command Q
shortcut into the Windows app.
So that people who are
using it on Mac
understand how to quit.
You're going to build in the
same user patterns that
they're expecting for Windows.
And it's the same
across mobile.
Like, I wouldn't tell you to
build your iPhone apps so that
they work and look the same
as your Android apps.
You want to have a consistent
experience between the
platform because that's
what they're doing
within a given context.
So for your app in particular,
what you want to do, what your
users are going to expect is
that if you're signed in but
your app is not in the
foreground, then it shouldn't
be consuming any resources.
And that's just going to
be their expectation.
Some may look to find
an Exit button.
But if you're not doing
anything, if you're not
consuming any resources, if the
phone's not going slower,
if you're not doing background
polling, you're not waking up
the phone--
you're just receiving
those updates using
Google Cloud Messaging.
Then they're going
to be happy.
They're not going to be looking
for something if
there's no reason
to look for it.
So that would be my big
piece of advice.
Don't try to over simplify
across devices.
Because in my experience
that tends to be what
bosses, what CEOs do.
They look at all of your apps
across all the different
phones
AUDIENCE: That's
our issue here.
The designers or product guys
basically want the same
features to be on all devices.
And my main concern or my main
issue as an Android developer
is to show them the Android
system is not the same as the
iOS system.
Or is not the same--
so you have the basic
conventions in Android, such
as the Home key or not showing
the exit option.
I agree that you don't need
an Exit button on your
application.
But basically I want you to
say it so I can have up a
judge overruling
on the matter.
So I can show it to our
designers and let them know
that basically what they're
doing is not is
not native to Android.
RETO MEIER: Sure.
And that's the sort of thing
we're trying to do a lot more
of these days.
I think the thing about Android,
particularly when we
got started is, it's open.
You can do anything.
But now we're trying to get to
the point where it's like, you
can do anything.
But we'd really like people to
do things in a consistent way
to make it easier for users.
And so we're trying to become
a little bit more aggressive
about telling people what
are the best practices.
You don't have to follow them.
No-one's going to take your app
out of Google Play if you
do things differently.
But at least something you can
show your design team and your
management team and say look,
this is the way that things
work on Android.
And if you want to do it
differently, you're going to
have to come up with something
very different.
Oh, I see what's
happened here.
DAN: [? I think ?]
your keynote.
RETO MEIER: Yeah.
So let me just jump over here
and I'll fix that problem.
Wonderful.
Boom.
Yeah, so it sounds like you're
on the same page as me.
So it sounds like we're
in good shape.
The challenge is explaining to
other people exactly why
that's the case.
And hopefully you can share with
them some of the stuff
that we talked about today.
And that may help change
their minds.
Thanks for your time, Yossi.
It's been a pleasure
talking to you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAN: I'm going to put Luke on.
Luke has a quick question
for you.
RETO MEIER: Cool.
Hey, Luke.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
I was just wondering about
something that I've seen
that's similar to what you're
talking about, but
not exactly the same.
Where someone hits the Back
button from an application
DAN: I love it.
Hangouts.
RETO MEIER: Hangouts.
Doing us a favor.
DAN: One second, guys.
RETO MEIER: We'll
be right back.
I love the technology
around here.
It never screws us over.
So, while we're waiting for
Luke to come back-- cool.
I think you're back.
All right.
So we missed some of that
because our Hangout crashed.
I'm going to go and assume that
sentence finished with,
you hit a Back button
that says, are you
sure you want to exit?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
RETO MEIER: Right.
Yeah, I hate that too.
That makes me very,
very angry.
There are very few exceptions
to that rule.
So navigation is actually
a good one.
Where if I hit the Back button
on Google navigation, it says
do you want to end
all [INAUDIBLE]?
Then you can either
say yes or no.
And that's reasonable.
Because I think it still
backs out of the app.
It just either does or doesn't
turn off the ongoing service.
And that's because, if I
accidentally hit Back while
I'm driving, I don't want to
then have to faff around with
Maps and Navigation to try
and get it back up.
So I like that, where it's
sort of a disruptive,
distracting behavior.
But it's just a normal
app, that's like--
it shouldn't be a difference,
right?
For most apps, if they don't
have an ongoing service,
hitting Back and then going,
oh whoops, and
then starting it again--
it should be the same as
starting it from scratch.
Or hitting Home and
going back.
So yeah, that's definitely an
anti-pattern that I really
hope dies a death.
AUDIENCE: That's kind of
what I was expecting.
RETO MEIER: Yeah.
Nothing too controversial
there.
Thanks for bringing it up.
We've got another hand wave.
I think fourth from the left.
DAN: Is that you again, Dave?
RETO MEIER: I think so.
I don't think that's it again.
AUDIENCE: That was just
my son waving.
RETO MEIER: Excellent.
Say hi to your son.
DAN: Who's up next?
Unfortunately, since the Hangout
crashed, I lost some
of the comments.
So if you guys were interested
in joining in
live, just let me know.
Wave your hand.
I'll put you guys on air.
RETO MEIER: Do we have any
comments on G+ or on YouTube
which may require
some responding?
DAN: There are actually a
lot of great comments.
I'm actually having a hard
time picking a good one.
They all seem to be replying to
each other about this very
debatable topic.
RETO MEIER: Oh, OK.
Excellent.
DAN: So let me go ahead and look
through a couple of them
and pick a great one for you.
I did see one down here.
Let me scroll down.
RETO MEIER: So while Daniel's
looking that up, I just want
to as well point out to you guys
that I'm going to try and
do this semi-regularly.
So if there are particular
topics which make you want to
flip a table, let me know
on G+, Twitter,
wherever you like.
And I'll see if I can put
together some argument.
Yes, Dave?
AUDIENCE: I actually have
a quick question.
Maybe we all have the
same question.
Are you going to flip that
table before you leave?
RETO MEIER: I was thinking
about it.
But my laptop is on it.
So I'm going to choose
not to and maybe save
that up for next week.
I will also take suggestions on
different kinds of tables.
I know that there were some
people who were disappointed
that I used a table which had
a cylindrical bottom, rather
than a more traditional
four-legged table, which the
emoticon would seem
to require.
But it's a learning
experience.
It's iterate and launch early
and iterate often.
So that's what we're going to do
here at Table Flip as well.
I'd really love to hear what
are some of the things that
drive you guys crazy.
As Justin was sort of
suggesting earlier--
a lot of the time, we as
developers all know how we
think apps should work.
And we get overruled by
designers or PMs who perhaps
aren't as familiar with
Android as we are.
So if you're looking for a way
to be able to present a
justification, do let me know.
And perhaps a six-minute
video will help.
I don't know how much so, but
it's probably worth a try.
Did you find a good question
or comment for
us to respond to?
DAN: I found a simple one which
is not too far beyond my
understanding.
It's about de-bouncing
the Back button.
For example, if you're heading
Back multiple times and
quickly try to escape an app,
which most users tend to do,
it'll take you back a lot
further than you intended to.
So what are your thoughts on
giving some feedback to users
when they're hitting Back in
a short amount of time?
RETO MEIER: So I think I'm going
to answer that question
by answering a slightly
different question, which is
really about navigation.
And I think that's another
vector into which people are
like, I want an Exit button,
because otherwise I'm in a
browser or in an app that I
have to hit Exit like a
million times before I
get out of the app.
If that's happening, that tells
me that the navigation
of your app is probably
overly complex.
It shouldn't require 15, 20 Back
button hits to get back
to the home screen
of your app.
So that's using the
[? app affordance ?]
or using a logo click to take
you back to the main screen of
your app, you really want to
be able to make it easy for
users to navigate, particularly
on phones and I
think still on tablets.
You really don't want to force
your users down a rabbit hole
of navigation.
You want to keep it as
simple as possible.
So rather than figuring out how
do I deal with the fact
that a user may hit the Back
button seven times instead of
six times to get to the home
screen, think about how to
make it easier for a user to
get to the home screen to
begin with.
I think that's probably a better
way to invest your time
than figuring out how
to do de-bounce too
many Back button clicks.
DAN: So we've got another good
comment from Paul W here.
He says that users traditionally
have grown up
being taught what the Exit
button does throughout their
entire lives.
And so you're on Windows
or you're on some
other operating system.
And everyone kind of feels
familiar with the Exit button.
And it's kind of part of
the foundation of how
we do things already.
RETO MEIER: Yes.
DAN: So maybe he's sort of
disagreeing with you.
RETO MEIER: I'll take that.
I mean, I think that's what I
was kind of talking about
right at the beginning.
So you may have missed the We'll
have just the video of
the [? rant ?] posted.
In fact, there's a link to it
in the G+ stream if you did
miss the very beginning.
But it's a good point right?
Like, old school, Exit
meant something.
Like if you have a
single-tasking operating
system, you need to have an Exit
in order to be able to do
something else.
And so, yeah, users have
gotten used to it.
Particularly us.
Like, I'm guessing people
watching this have been using
computers since shortly after
exiting the womb.
And so those patterns really
getting ingrained with us.
But new users--
they're not thinking
of it that way.
Particularly phone users who
don't really think of their
phone as being a computer
that runs apps.
They just think of it
as a device that
lets them do stuff.
I mean, I remember reading
a survey--
I think it was late last year
or early this year--
which asked people, do you use
the internet on your phone?
And most said, no, I don't use
the internet on my phone.
And the follow-up question
is like, well, do
you check your email?
Do you update Facebook?
Do you use Twitter?
And they're like, yeah,
definitely do
all of those things.
And it's like--
the internet, how
does it work?
That's what's making all
of these things work.
But people don't think
of it that way.
All of the implementation
details about how these apps
work-- the fact that there
are apps running in a
multi-tasking operating system
connecting to the internet
over ethernet or a cell network,
TCP/IP connection.
They don't know any of that.
They don't care about
any of that.
They just want to do something,
like order a taxi,
or check their email, or update
Twitter, or take a photo.
And how it all works means
nothing to them.
And so in that context, Exit
doesn't make any sense.
Like, I just want to
update Twitter.
And then I want to
take a photo.
I don't want to have to think
about exiting one app to start
up another.
So it's really about changing
those paradigms.
And getting people thinking
in a different way.
I mean, you can say anything
is old school.
Like, I remember when I was in
high school thinking, I can't
believe it.
This new computer I'm going
to buy doesn't have a 5
and 1/4 inch disk.
That's ridiculous.
I mean I know I mainly use the
3 and 1/2 inch floppies now.
But the 5 and 1/4 is
never going away.
Yeah, it went away.
And then the 3 and 1/2 inch went
away not too long enough
afterwards.
And then hard drives started
to end up in the terabytes.
My point is that
things change.
And I think as developers,
we need to adapt to that.
And the trend is really to try
and make things easier and
easier for users, so they don't
have to think about how
do I use a computer?
They just do stuff.
And then the OS does
all the hard work.
It's the same when we started
switching to garbage collected
programming languages.
Like a lot of folks back in the
day were like, oh that's
ridiculous.
You don't have to manage
your own memory.
But you know what?
It's easier.
It makes our job easier.
And it lets us focus on
features, rather than on the
bits and pieces that go into
making an app work.
I think we're just about
out of time.
We've already gone
15 minutes later
than I initially proposed.
But we've had a lot of good
comments and conversations.
So I didn't want to
cut anyone off.
But is there anyone on the
Hangouts which would like to
throw in a few final thoughts,
comments, disagreements?
Could you speak up?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RETO MEIER: Oh, you're
very welcome.
AUDIENCE: I had a question.
And I was wondering
if you could do a
session on unit testing?
RETO MEIER: OK.
Yeah, unit testing
is a good one.
I think testing is something
which we probably don't have
as much information out there
for Android as we should do,
considering how important
it is.
So yeah, we'll definitely feed
that back into the team.
And see if we can get an
Office Hours Hangout or
something around unit testing
best practices,
those sorts of things.
It's a great idea.
DAN: Cool man.
I think that's it.
RETO MEIER: All right.
Thank you very much everyone.
Let's see.
Yes, so that's it for today.
I'll be back next time for
another Android anti-pattern
that makes me want
flip a table.
I don't know what it is yet.
So if you've got suggestions,
let me know.
And I will throw the furniture
on your behalf.
Until then, my name
is Reto Meier.
We were ably assisted
by Daniel [? Fan. ?]
And thank you for watching.